comment expliquez-vous aujourd'hui que
la gauche soit si basses dans les
sondages
je crois d'abord parce que tout
simplement la gauche c'est fini voilà
bah oui c'est fini depuis un moment en
2001 avec mon ami jacques cotta nous
avions écrit un livre qui s'appelait
l'illusion pluriel pourquoi la gauche
n'est plus la gauche alors pourquoi la
gauche c'est fini tout simplement parce
que la gauche celle date de naissance à
vous pour la situer autour de l' affaire
dreyfus et puis la date de mort est bien
allé un peu lente mais en gros du moment
où le parti socialiste a acté qu'il
était impossible d'envisager la
transformation sociale l' affaire est
réglée ce qui s'est passé c'est que
lorient encore un clivage votre gauche
et ce clivage il est à l'intérieur d'un
système donné il est à l'intérieur on va
dire des classes dominantes tout
simplement il ya une droite de la classe
dominante et puis quelle grosse de la
classe dominante mais au fond là ce qui
avait fait la gauche ses terres cette
alliance entre le radicalisme et le
socialisme ça ça n'existe plus
d'ailleurs c'était ni une affaire
nouvelle parce que mon de l'affairé
dreyfus c'est là que s'est noué cette
alliance mais avant les socialistes ne
se disait ni à droite ni à gauche la
droite et la gauche c'était une affaire
qui regardaient les bourgeois ce qui
fait d'ailleurs qui explique qu'ils ont
eu lieu un peu de réticence à s'engager
dans l' affaire dreyfus parce que au
départ alors pour tout ça évidemment
[Musique]
mais au départ il se disait ce une
affaire entre eux et l'alliance qui sait
nous à ce moment là entre le radicalisme
c'était républicain et qui avait aussi
une certaine doctrine ans se souvenir
que les philosophes du radicalisme et
n'étaient pas des penseurs à verte et
prince était debout serrés puissance à
l'époque les bons week-ends et cette
alliance avec le socialiste henri
socialistes pensaient que cette alliance
transitoire c'était une étape pour aller
vers une transformation sociale
semblait nécessaire à partir du moment
où cette transformation sociale n'est
plus l'objectif
il ya plus de cet antagonisme pour de
gauche et donc la gauche elle se réduit
à être l'ailé gauche du capital c'est
tout
[Musique]